so
what i'd really like to do
let me start again
so of all the videos i've been involved
with for 60 symbols on numberphile and
brady's million other channels the one
i'm least happy with by far
is the one we did in entropy we even
then did we followed that up with a sort
of mia culpa where i uh
pointed out well there are some
important details here that we glossed
over
i really want to revisit entropy and
brady's going to indulge me which is is
great well he might and might not
a lot of it stems from this
the work of this guy is a guy called
frank lambert and notice it says
disorder a cracked crutch for support
and entropy discussions so every time
you hear entropy mentioned or the vast
majority of times and certainly as
undergraduates and certainly in that 60
symbols video we do the same thing we
make this link between entropy and
disorder for a person who isn't a
scientist even for a person who is a
scientist that's actually a very
difficult and very confusing link to
make because for example the argument is
that you know
entropy is always increasing disorders
always increasing how does this happen
so this is from a kid's crystal growing
kid so we get crystals how do we get
lovely structures like this beautiful
structures this is this crystal
structure of silicon and we can get this
extended over you know
huge pieces of silicon how much more
ordered do you want to get
and yet the argument is that disorder is
always increasing how then do you take
you know atoms in a melt or atoms in the
gas phase and this is how we grow
silicon they're pretty disordered you'd
argue and yet they hit the surface and
they grow and they build and they form
this structure so that seems to be for
on the face of it pretty good example of
something which is very disorder turning
into something which is very ordered
that's the issue with using order and
disorder to explain entropy and this is
something that this guy lambert
has been banging on about for quite some
time and quite rightly banging on about
because it's exceptionally exceptionally
misleading
i'm going to cover just very briefly um
two two aspects of this you know you
could then quite rightly ask me well you
know how does it happen then does this
break the second north thermodynamics
the fact that you're seeing this
apparent disorder to order transition
instead of the other way around have the
laws of thermodynamics suddenly gone
wrong have i misunderstood everything
the important thing here is you've got
to take into account the entire system
you've got to take into account whether
the system is closed or open if there's
energy or matter flow all of those
different things we can even reduce it
further to make the the argument of this
um
even simpler the important thing that
we're neglecting when we talk about you
know just the atoms forming an order
disorder is what's the role of energy
and in particular when those atoms bond
they give off heat energy and that heat
energy is an exceptionally important
contribution to that i'm going to use
these disorder of the system
we've got to take the whole system into
consideration also if you take a whole
system into consideration there is
nothing saying that over here
entropy can't go down as long as over
here
a lot more entropy is is produced and
the net
um
value of the entropy goes up but the
problem is
in many cases particularly when it's put
across to a sort of general public a
general audience that you know may not
have have years of undergraduate or
postgraduate experience with
thermodynamics for example
many times disorder is just taken as
well you know this is ordered and lots
and lots of molecules in the gas phase
are disordered that's that's really um
damaging and it's why lamberts is here
disorder a cracked crutch for supporting
entropy discussions what i want to talk
about is the work actually of a really
really impressive group um in michigan
we had a guy called uh sorry for so many
papers but i've got i've really got to
do give credit where credit's true this
guy dean frenkel so dan frankel is a
physical chemist in cambridge he's done
a lot of work very important work very
insightful work on these type of issues
in terms of phase transitions order
disorder entropy something called
enthalpy energy etc all these type of
things he gave us a wonderful colloquium
a couple of weeks back and i sat there
listening to that colloquium and feeling
even more guilty about that entropy
video we did a while back he really sort
of
you know motivated me to to to examine
this again and one group's work he
mentioned a number of times is sharon
glotter's group at the university of
michigan her group does really
remarkable computer simulations which
show that purely from entropy alone
throw away the energy consideration so
what you can do in a computer it's very
very straightforward oh we'll use these
two molecules right in real life and
we'll talk about this later brady in
real life those two molecules will
attract each other okay you can't get
rid of that attraction they will always
attract each other if there is nothing
surrounding them you can put them in a
solvent and you can tune that solvent so
you get rid of that or
minimize that attractive interaction in
a computer what's great is you can just
turn it off
and so they get rid of the
energy term
and they're left with just the entropy
term and we've got it again for the
pedantic 60 symbols viewers i know
there's a difference between free energy
and energy etc but we're just going to
think about the attractive interaction
there we're going to turn on the
computer simulations they turn off that
attraction they turn off that potential
energy contribution
and they just focus on the entropy so
what we've got are what are called hard
spheres
and it's the most elegant example of
where entropy can produce order and i
got in touch with them yesterday said we
were probably going to do a 60 symbols
video on this and they got back in touch
really quickly a guy called michael
engel sent me some videos um of uh the
work they've done uh and
it's it's really quite neat i'm just
gonna show you one of those videos so
what's happening here is that the green
bits are the ordered regions the red
bits are the disordered regions and what
you can see a function of time as this
thing proceeds it gets more and more
ordered purely due to entropy and you
might say hang on
how does that work how is entropy
driving this this seems to go entirely
against the conventional idea i've got a
bigger question there okay yeah what's
the difference between an ordered sphere
and another one sorry there were just a
bunch of spheres in a box no no no but
it's a relationship of the spheres with
each other the positions of the spheres
with each other so you can look at
something called correlation function
you can see how one sphere is related to
its neighbors and you can use that to
work out the degree of order something
called an order parameter so that's been
kind of ordered itself like like a
beehive exactly that's it it ordered
itself just due to entropy so this is
why this idea of associating entropy
with disorder is really misleading from
a number of perspectives so what is
entropy right so i wrote this down
at the start of that video so entropy is
boltzmann's constant
times the log of w what's w w is the
number of microstates sharon glotts in a
wonderful tedx video she does actually
just says well let's just call w ways
and w is the total number of ways you
can arrange the um
molecules in the system
so if we've got where's the trusty balls
again this is why entropy is generally
associated with
disorder because if we've got i really
need a box
right just to keep them in place that's
all that the box is there for the
important thing is
there are very very very very very many
more ways of organizing these molecules
so that they're disordered so that
they're spread out than there are of
forming them in inordered structures
right
that's the essence of entropy it's the
fact that there are so many more ways of
spreading the molecules out then of
clamping them together having them in an
order structure however
what glutzer's group do this is really
clever and others have done it before
them but um there's something very very
elegant about glottal's work what they
do
is that they set the system up
so that there are more ways
for the
the the spheres to be um ordered than
there are to be disordered is that by
overcrowding because their box looks
very crowded exactly there's a key
aspect of of the the the um what's
called hard sphere interaction so
they're they're crashing into each other
and bouncing off that's very very
important that's a very important aspect
of it and getting computer simulations
are great because you can just switch
off the parameters actually getting that
it like that in real life is very very
tricky but as i said groups have done it
in the past by controlling how the
particle trying to switch off the
potential energy between the particles i
mean they're just lo they're loading the
dice beyond belief let's talk about
nature when that crystal forms in my
solution or on the on a surface out of
the gas
are you saying
it was more likely to happen like there
were more ways it could happen than not
happen or is that different so the
important thing there is you've got to
take the whole thermodynamics into
consideration does the entropy term
sorry brady it's not going to be i'd
love to give you a straightforward
answer but it's not we have something
called the free energy and what we've
got to do is take into account
the potential energy between these so
how much they want to sort of stick
together or bond together that's one
term and then the other term is the
entropy and it's actually an entropy
multiplied by the temperature so
temperature plays a key role so it's the
balance of those two things the balance
of the energy or what the chemist called
enthalpy and entropy that really
dictates how things go
and it's even more complicated than that
because that's the thermodynamics you've
also got to take the kinetics into
consideration but that's a whole other
video